pour une conférence à la dernière minute
il était à New York pour s'adresser au
Conseil de sécurité
c'est que la tension monte entre les
deux pays Moscou a expulsé le numéro 2
de l'ambassade américaine sans raison
sont les États-Unis
au même moment la Russie remet une
lettre à Washington où elle dénonce le
nombre alarmant de militaires de l'Otan
à sa frontière
le secrétaire d'État américain ne marche
pas ces mots il prévient que Moscou est
en train de manufacturer un prétexte
pour envahir l'Ukraine
la découverte d'une fausse commune
inventée une attaque de drone contre les
civils et même une fausse ou réelle
attaque chimique depuis le début
Washington publie toutes les
informations même si elle jugeait
confidentielle du service de
renseignement selon le Pentagone il
serait 150000 militaires russes amassés
à la frontière ukrainienne
la menace est très élevée l'invasion
russe en Ukraine pour arriver dans
quelques jours
mais il y a aussi un message pour la
Chine
il faut que l'Europe arrête de dépendre
du gaz russe
dans des pendre
la Russie affirme qu'elle n'a pas à
l'intention d'envahir l'Ukraine mais
qu'elle va prendre ce qu'elle appelle
des mesures militaires techniques ici à
la Maison Blanche Joe Biden affirme que
malgré tout la voie diplomatique n'est
toujours pas épuisée